je vais te détruire avec mon turbo glove
l'armé ultime contre la menace robotique
mais pour être un vrai héros tu vas
devoir sauver qu'un petit aime aller
qu'est ce que tu as dans les mains cette
hausse est un comics sa part de kwara ce
turbo raider signal
je me suis toujours demandé s'il y avait
là bas c'est un peu poussiéreux ils
devront je pourrais te montrer si tu
veux ici nous faisons les choses avec un
peu plus de joie de vivre
où est-elle relancée la vie c'est comme
vous le savez la situation est critique
le nombre de victimes maximum a été
atteint les faits sont des êtres qui
exactement sur cour ait et la façade à
nouveau frappé ces satanés machine avec
tout ce que nous avons tous troubles et
tuent les airs apporte-moi lente et sur
des piques vais retrouver une vieille
connaissance
on va directement chez tous alors
liquide
alors si
[Musique]
le sort de notre futur est entré en jeu
rémy être un peu plus comme le vrai
turbo reda mais tu peux sûrement
[Musique]